storytelling is the most underrated
skill in business is because I don't
think that people realize it's happening
when it's happening and most of all I
don't think that many people really good
at when I watch a Steve Jobs keynote
about a new product I don't care about
the new tech I care about the iPad or
the iPhone I could about the way he was
presenting it when I see David Blaine
this is a magician if you ever pay
attention what he's doing he's story
telling you the whole way and met it's a
big kid so if you understand what the
consumer wants then you backtrack and
you tell the story to get them
emotionally there that's how things sell
that's marketing the reason I think that
people are missing why things succeed is
because of storytelling and I think it's
overlooked I think people look at the
X's and O's and the black and the white
but I think storytelling when done right
takes a product that should have sold a
hundred million dollars worth of stuff
and it sells a billion dollars worth in
2001 it snowed on December 23rd the
busiest day of the year in a liquor
store a woman called us and her case of
behringer White Zinfandel wasn't
delivered the entire cake cost $45 we're
doing about 40,000 dollars an hour in
the store she calls I find out about it
I was on the floor selling I am the
premiere salesman on the floor and we're
debating what to do she needs it for her
Christmas dinner I grabbed the case
throw it in my car and drive to deliver
it it takes me two and a half hours the
woman was a hundred and ninety four
years old
we didn't have a lot of lifetime value
on the back end there she looked like
Yoda and the best part was I delivered
it all pumped with myself and she said
great and close the door
awesome everybody especially my dad who
was pissed that I left because all the
customers that came in asking for me or
that I could have sold everybody who's
baffled I can't tell you what the ROI of
driving through the snow in my car to
deliver a case of $45 pink shot to a
woman that looked like Yoda was but I
can tell you this over the next two to
three years that story became the
foundation of how we treated every
single customer it became our
competitive edge and those are the
things that matter to me you just
watched two amazing clips from Gary
Vaynerchuk take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]